the speed of an orbiting object is  caused by the gravity pulling on it  gravity is stronger when there is more  mass so the more mass there is in here  the fastest object will go distance also  affects the strength of gravity so an  object out here will go slower because  the force is weaker out there it's the  same for galaxies this stuff is really  far away so should be going pretty slow  but when we measure it it's going way  too fast this could be explained by  adding some matter and here as we go out  to give up the speed that matter is dark  matter there are two things dark matter  could be ordinary stuff called macho's  or massive compact halo objects that we  can't really see like failed stars and  cold dust that sits around like bricks  supplying that extra mass or it could be  extraordinary stuff once weakly  interacting massive particles a new kind  of particle with mass but there doesn't  interact with anything so we can't  really see it but we are searching for  clues